now I couldn't live a much better life
but just would it just suffered a little
bit more when you set goals when you
have an intention on something that you
want to change about your life your
brain helps you what it does is it opens
up a checklist when I fell off my bike
my dad hit me if little weenies get up
want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
oh hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you are a genius
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the three secrets that
success is based on
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one outwork the chart with David
Goggins I believe in a higher power
don't know the name don't know where
it's coming from billions like that but
I believe that this power and visualize
me real quick let's say it's a man up
there a woman whatever and they have a
chart and when you're born they say
David Goggins born February 17th 1975 at
6 a.m. they write the chart down because
they can see everything they know
exactly what you're supposed to be they
know what you're supposed to be you die
you go to so-called heaven you arrive at
heaven I'm 300 pounds I retired as an
eco lab guy which is okay just a job
whatever I go up there and God looks at
me and he's chosen my chart and my toner
in there says you were supposed to be a
Navy SEAL
you're supposed to be her in 85 pounds
you're supposed to be one the smartest
people in the plant this this all this
you see this and now you're in heaven
you made to heaven but you're like God I
supposed to live that life I'm supposed
to live that life and then you find out
that the reason why because we all think
that if we pray on it if we do this if
we do that whatever if we don't work we
just never could magically happen for us
no I believe that when I'm all said and
done with my whole job is to outwork the
chart
wherever the chart says about me to
all-knowing power up there I want to get
up there and say him look at me and say
I know everything I didn't see this
I didn't see this I want to feel that I
want to get to the other end of this
world and however I'm being judged
whoever's judging me to look at me and
said I did not know I had you at 185 had
you that this but all this other I was
riding as you were living it I want to I
want to find more all I can and in that
second you have to dive in that to find
more because if you're not willing to go
in there and face yourself I can find
anything you can live right here on
surface man right here on surface so if
there is an ending to this world and
there is somewhere to go in this a
judgement you're gonna get there and you
might see a chart and that chart may
tell you who the you should have been
and now you get to rest your life to
think about that man I could have lived
a much better life I just would it just
suffered a little bit more secret number
to take action with Mel Robbins one
night Chris have gone to bed I had been
struggling struggling struggling we
still had all the same problems I we
stalled a lien on the house still facing
bankruptcy still fighting like crazy I
was still unemployed
he still they still hadn't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and I was about to turn off the TV and
there on the the TV there was this
rocket launching and I thought oh my
gosh I am gonna launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship like NASA right here
had launched me out of that bed and I'm
gonna move so fast that I don't think
mmm I'm gonna beat my breed now here's a
really interesting point I talked a lot
about your instincts and inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that I've done
for the book and and all the speaking
that I do what I've discovered that's
fat
sedating is actually when you set goals
when you have an intention on something
that you want to change about your life
your brain helps you what it does is it
opens up a checklist and then your brain
goes to work trying to remind you yeah
of that intention that you set and it's
really important to develop the skill
and I say that word purposefully the
skill of knowing how to hear that inner
wisdom and that intention kicking in and
leaning into it quickly so for me my
brain saying that's it right there
move as fast as a rocket Mel I wanted to
change my life
and I think most people that are
miserable or that are that are really
like dying to be great and dying to have
more we want to change we want to live a
better life we want to create more for
our families we want to be happier the
the desire is there again it's about how
do you go from knowledge to actions so
the first thing in the story that's
important is realizing that the answer
was in me and my mind was telling me pay
attention I could have also been the
Bourbon anyway the next morning the
alarm goes off and I pretended NASA was
there
it's a stupidest story I literally went
5 4 3 2 1 I counted out loud and then I
stood up and I'll never forget standing
there in my bedroom it was dark it was
cold it was winter in Boston and for the
first time in 3 months I had beaten my
habit of hitting the snooze button I
couldn't believe it and I thought wait a
minute counting backwards that is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard in my
entire life well the next morning I used
it again and it worked the next morning
I used it again and it worked the next
morning I used it again and it worked
and then I started to notice something
really interesting there were moments
all day long all day long just like that
five-second moment in bed where I knew
knowledge what I should do
and if I didn't move within 5 seconds
my brain would step in and talk me out
of it every human being has a
five-second window might even be shorter
for you you have about a five-second
window in which you can move from idea
to action before your brain kicks into
full gear and sabotages any change in
behavior because remember your brain is
wired to stop you from doing things that
are uncomfortable or uncertain or scary
it's your job to learn how to move from
those ideas that could change everything
into acting on also if you want to have
more confidence check on my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below what if I can become
someone that no one thinks I can be and
just that just me talking about that I
have hair growing up on my arms you
might want to get honest with yourself
like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make honey
you want people with a like mind and
that are better than you smarter than
you more intelligent than you to get on
your bus and secret number three the
last one before very special bonus clip
is man up with Dan Pena all UK guys
probably had bicycles with trainer
wheels right on the little wheels on the
side of the bicycle and when you ride it
and you didn't fall off and then when
the your parents took the trainer wheels
off what happened you fell over on your
head and what if your mother probably
and maybe your father oh poor baby poor
baby and rub your head when I fell off
my bike my dad hit me just little
weenies get up stand up stop crying
oh yeah yeah I mean man up and now look
at me I mean I wish love got the job
done I swear to God I do but it doesn't
and God doesn't get the job done either
god helps those who help themselves now
I have a special bonus clip with Jordan
Belfort on how to master your craft that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one how are you
going to outwork your chart number two
where do you need to take immediate
action in your business and number three
how are you going to man or woman up
today and if you're gonna take immediate
action after watching this video give me
a hash tag believe down in the comments
as well let me tell you what this is
this is probably one of the most
important things when it comes to
success in every endeavor you go for
whatever job every whatever business you
start there's gonna be certain
specialized skills that are required and
you need to become extraordinary at them
let me tell your story how did this
whole thing happen in my life right how
did I write this book okay how did I go
out and take this book and turn it into
this whole business that formed the
movie and a global brand right well let
me taste like I was in jail okay
and when I show off the chair who's my
bunkmate believe it or not Tom Lee Chong
from Cheech and Chong
you know Cheech and Chong he's my
bunkmate right now I didn't go to I
wasn't in the worst jail although I'll
admit I wasn't getting but each night my
bones not bad it was a federal prison
camp
okay it was okay well but still jails
Jail it sucks right Tommy's my bunk make
you're both celebrity put us together in
one cube it was a little cube you later
he is writing a book right so Tommy says
to me oh my god we told you other
stories at night and I haven't rolling
on the floor laughing man so by night
three girls you know I thought you were
making this up but my wife Gold you it's
all true you live this crazy life you
got to write a book you got to get it
right about this stuff so I said I don't
know how to write he says well just
write the way you speak the way you tell
a story so well guess what I tried that
doesn't work writing and speaking are
very different skill sets they just are
completely different and for the first
month or so I'm writing a couple of
pages I showed them to Tommy
he reads those well that really sucked
like thanks Tommy tell me really think
right
and I was depressed that I could do
anything out in paper that was
meaningful or funny right and I always
was gonna stop and I hate quitting
anything and I went to the prison
library one day of his prisons his
library and I stumbled upon a book
called bonfire of the vanities by Tom
Wolfe and I started reading this book
and it's like oh my god and this is how
I want to write so I plow through the
book finish it I start back at cage
where I take out a yellow highlighter
and I use this book like the textbook
and for three months I ripped apart
every single word I broke down Tom
Wolfe's strategy for writing sometimes
it doesn't matter how much you want
something or how hard you willing to
work to get something if you don't
possess the actual skill set that's
required to do it its delusion and most
people don't get that they'll try to go
into a business that's sales based but
not master the art of sales in
persuasion they'll try to go into
another type of business not mess
whatever it might be they don't master
their craft first thing you have to do
is say okay I want to do this what
specialized skills ready to learn and
take the time to learn them master your
craft
if you want to know the five morning
routines that will transform your life
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we don't
stop no more that there is one habit
that I have adopted in the last three
years